autre affaire de pédophilie cette fois
ci concernant la loi du silence observé
par un homme d'église monseigneur pican
évêque de bayeux le procureur a rock qui
est quatre à six mois de prison avec
sursis contre cet homme sûr de son bon
droit
parce que dit il il protégeait le secret
professionnel il n'a donc pas dénoncé un
prêtre pédophile yasmina farber et
marine massa il aura fallu attendre la
fin des débats pour que monseigneur
piquant sorte de sa tour d'ivoire de sa
réserve
l'évêque s'est adressé aux victimes
après deux journées exceptionnelles
j'ai mieux perçu la dimension dramatique
de la pédophilie et les dégâts qu'elle
provoque sur les personnes d'expérience
m'appellera sur bien des terrains à
exercer mon gouvernement responsable au
service de l'église d'une manière
beaucoup plus accordées à certaines
situations de détresse dans son
réquisitoire jacques-yves seconde à
rappelle que ce n'est pas le procès de
l'église mais celui d'un homme d'église
qui a manqué à son devoir de
dénonciation le procureur parle d'
immobilisme d'attentisme
selon lui le problème du secret
professionnel ne se pose pas lévesque
n'a pas été alerté par le prêtre il
était important de marquer le coup de
faire de ce procès un symbole et qui
évidemment la sanction doit tenir compte
à la fois de la gravité des faits de la
souffrance des enfants et de la
personnalité psychorigide qualifié par
le procureur de l'évêque
on dit que monseigneur piquant à une
volonté de dissimulation je ne pense pas
que c'était une volonté de dissimulation
je pense qu'il ya des concours d une
situation très difficile il a avancé de
bonne voie la défense a plaidé toute la
subtilité de l'option de conscience
mais les victimes de l'abbé bissey
repartent avec ce sentiment définitif le
silence de l'évêque était coupable
le tribunal se laisse le temps de la
réflexion pour ce jugement la maison
judiciaire sera dit le 4 septembre
prochain